Hi everyone, I'm Vicos. I'm a software
development manager with AWS at Amazon.
I'm Linda. I'm a developer advocate at
AWS and in this video we're going to
talk about the software development life
cycle and specifically how you can use
Genai throughout that life cycle. We're
going to focus on Amazon Q developer
which is an AI coding assistant and
we're going to show you where you could
use it in all the different parts of
that. So I'm going to throw it to Vicash
because he as a manager always gets a
very common question regarding this. One
of the most common questions that I hear
from the engineering team is how can
they incorporate generative AI practices
into their software development life
cycle or the SDLC. For those of us who
don't know what SDLC is, it's a process
of building and releasing software to
our customers. We generally start with
the planning phase where we gather
requirements, product feedbacks etc.
Then we go to the create phase where we
actually build the software application
itself. Then we test it, do end- to-end
testing, integration testing,
penetration testing to make sure that
the software that we are building is
safe for our customers. We then deploy
it and finally we maintain it and
modernize it. Over time depending upon
the feedback we go through this cycle
all over again. So let's get right into
it. Amazon Q developer is a coding
assistant that is also in your IDE can
be even in your CLI and terminal
actually also has a GitHub extension and
can be also in different parts of the
life cycle. Right? So I'm going to show
you where you could get started. One of
the cool things is if you install it in
the command line or the IDE doesn't
require an AWS account. All you have to
do is go to this page, click get started
for free and choose which one you want.
Once you do that, I'll just quickly show
you here. Here you have an example of
how it appears in Visual Studio Code
over here. And we're going to build,
don't worry. Here is a way it appears in
the CLI. What we can do next is jump
into the CLI version because that's the
most lightweight version for you to
install Amazon Q. You all have a command
line on your computer. And here you can
do either the planning phase or if
you've already done the planning phase
somewhere else, you can go straight into
creating and coding. So let's get into
it. I have an idea. Why don't we build a
game for our viewers today? So this game
is called 2048 or 2048. So we have
multiple tiles. The goal of the game is
to merge two tiles of the same number
and then the numbers double. The goal is
to reach a total of 2048 or 2048. So
here if you see we are merging two tiles
of two they become four. We merging two
tiles of four they become 8. We merging
two tiles of eight making them 16 and so
on and so forth. This is a really fun
game to build. So I actually think let's
get right into the CLI and try it out.
So everyone has a command line, right?
So in order to start Q once you install
it, we showed you where to install it.
Now Vicos gave me a challenge. We have
to build this 2048 game. To start it,
all I have to actually write is Q. I
press enter. If you aren't sure what to
do and how to use it, you can just type
with natural language right now and
start just talking to it also as a chat
also to idate. But if you want to see
all the other options you have, you
could do /help and you will see also
that you have all these uh different
commands as well as mcp if you would
like to use that and other tips. So for
now I want to build a 2048 game in
Python using fast API. Yeah, let's do
using fast API.
Uh let's use poetry. Using poetry. Let's
see what it comes up with. So now it's
giving me the plan. It's telling me
here's what I I'm I'm going to do. And
now I have an ability to either accept
each step by pressing Y and enter or I
can just do T and trust it. Vicash,
should we trust it? I I trust Q. Of
course, this is a demo. If you're
building in production, we always
recommend reviewing the code. But here,
we're going to trust it and it'll start
running. And now you can see how long
each step is taking as well. All right.
So now, while we were chatting, this was
generating some 2048 code here. One
thing I forgot and check this out. One
thing I forgot is look, it's putting it
in inside just my my regular folder. I
actually wanted to move the whole thing
into my development folder. So guess
what? I could actually asked it, can you
move this project to my development
folder? So now it will move it in there.
That's actually pretty nifty little
hack. Yeah, cuz I always forget when I
do this to put it in the right place.
All right, so now uh it's saying the the
project is set up. You could see that
here it appears in my development
folder. Awesome. I think this code
actually looks good. I am really happy
that it is using first API rightly. It
has a response model. It has created
post APIs. Agreed. What's cool Vicos?
You could also use this in your IDE
right and open the folder structure cuz
of course this is more coming out in the
CLI but you can use Q in your ID of
choice. Given that my engineering team
relies on VS Code, IntelliJ, Eclipse,
um, and everyone has their own
preferences, right? And Amazon Q
developer touches all these touch points
which makes it very seamless of an
experience. It even created a read me.
Vicash, which part of the software
development life cycle is that
awesome.
So now it tells me what my project
structure is. It created in the
development folder even though I only
remembered midway. And it tells me how
to run it. I think this is a great start
but is it production ready? I would say
no too. Why don't we add unit test? Yes.
So let's open it in the IDE. So why
don't we start with adding unit test to
make sure that it's production ready. So
let's start with that. I quickly open up
in my IDE and I start invoking my Amazon
Q developer agent for test for
generating unit test by invoking / test.
So here I'm doing /ash test. It
automatically invokes the Amazon Q
developer agent and it quickly starts
looking at the code itself. Once it's
done, let's look at the generated code.
Here we see it is able to understand all
pieces of the code and we have I think a
good amount of test. It is amazing that
it was able to also understand the state
and created relevant test for the state
management itself. So I think this looks
pretty pretty robust. I generally use
slash test a lot. There's also a feature
called /dev which is for feature
development. You can give it a prompt in
the IDE. It will automatically
understand the entire project as context
and build context aware features for me.
So let's go ahead and quickly ask you to
fix my bugs by just saying fix and
giving the error message. It quickly
analyzed my
codebase. It figured out where the error
is, gave me the code. I applied it and
now let's see what
happens. Voila. I have a working code
for a game with unit test. Let's do one
more thing. Why don't we generate
documentations before we raise a pull
request? So let's invoke the /doc which
is the Amazon Q developer agent to
generate documentation. I go ahead I
quickly pass on /doc. I ask it to create
a readme. So initially there was a
readme generated but now that we have a
code and we have unit test I I want to
see how it does better. So it quickly
started my summarizing my codebase
started going through my source files.
So now I see a documentation it is able
to understand my source code. It gives
me the instruction which was pretty much
the same last time as well. This is
interesting. Now my API endpoints also
have relevant examples as my
troubleshooting documentation and it
also gave me a data flow diagram of how
my state is being managed. And I think
one of the next steps could be deploying
or having a PR. But did you know also
that Q is available inside GitHub and
you can actually build inside GitHub. It
has agents there and I'm going to show
you really quick that as well. So if you
like to build on GitHub and not leave
GitHub, you can also do that. Awesome.
going to give you a quick overview. So
head over to Q developer in marketplace
and GitHub and all you have to do is
choose which repos you want. You can put
all or a few and now you can actually
either use an existing issue or create a
new one. Apply a label here. Let's say
we're just doing development agent. And
based on that issue, it will generate
code. It will tell you when the PR is
ready. And you can then look at the
files that were changed. And now if we
want to change something in the PR, you
can actually add comments and request
changes like I normally would in a
review and then request the changes. So
it does it again. So you don't even have
to leave GitHub. And then Q also
automatically runs code scans and fixes
it right in the PR. And so it's pretty
awesome how you can use also agents
right inside GitHub with Q. We talked
about where we could code which is
idees, CLI, GitHub. We're building this
2048 uh uh game. We even ran tests. We
have documentation. So what's next in
the life cycle? So the next would be to
deploy it to our cloud services already.
So one of the most common things and I'm
guilty of it is saying works on my
machine right to make this game an
actual production ready. will deploy it
into AWS console and in the background I
use the /dev agent in the IDE to
actually generate SAM scripts and deploy
my application. You you know what's
something interesting I found what that
our application was actually not running
the right way in production. Oh yes. So
I need to investigate. So let's go ahead
and do that. So here I come to my AWS
console. I go into my cloudatch. Let's
first look at the lambda where I
deployed through SAM and I'm looking at
the logs and I quickly see there is some
import error happening in the lambda
itself. Now I can start investigating
the application directly in the console
itself using Amazon Q
developer. The Amazon Q developer AI
operations automatically starts looking
at the log group and all the associated
resources. It creates a topology and
then figures out the root cause for me.
I don't have to spend time debugging. I
can look at the graphs. I can figure out
what's going on and come back and fix my
application. It's so easy for developers
to actually know what's happening rather
than trying to find the right time stamp
and create reports or incident reports
for the team. So this feature enables me
to quickly look what what's wrong in my
application and I can go back in time
and go ahead and fix it. I think this I
was happy with this report. So let's
just go ahead and close the
investigation. Taking this game to
production, I think when we saw the
errors and Amazon Q developer helped us
debug what's the reason. I think one of
the takeaways for me in this particular
situation is to think of infra upfront
how your application is going to the
customers. I think if that's something
that we would have done early on, we
wouldn't have right faced this. I should
have asked QCLI to generate an ice. We
should have thought about in front. We
are both part of the software
development life cycle. Vicos,
so we should have thought about it up
front. What was your takeaways? My
takeaway is kind of similar to yours
where we have to kind pre-plan. So that
planning phase might have other things.
And maybe one way to actually follow
best practices is to actually ask even
in the CLI we could say what is the best
way for me to plan for something that's
a bit more robust right and production
ready and follow best practices and you
can iterate before you ever actually
have the code saved anywhere right or
like generate and iterate. I think the
planning part where you can of course if
you're deploy deploying to the cloud use
IA and then being able to use utilize Q
in different ways for your use case in
so many different locations is helpful
of course it's always you are the person
planning you're the manager and AI just
is just helping you with all these
tedious tasks and almost becoming your
assistant in so many places there so
it's awesome you have it at all these
different places but of course it's on
you as we learn to to be able to uh do
this responsibly um and I love the
security scans and the monitoring and
observability because I think it's helps
a lot in mitigating issues. So
absolutely one of the things that you
rightly pointed out is as engineers and
with generative AI and Amazon Q
developer the planning phase might
probably also include planning your
prompts because prompt engineering is
going to be a very important skill set
to make sure that you get desired
outputs from the from the large models
and the agents. So for anyone who's
watching this and wants to try Q. First
of all, you could try it for free in the
IDE, you could try it for free in the
CLI, you could try for free in GitHub
and so many different locations. So
definitely give it a try, play around
with it yourself. So you could head over
to
aws.mamazon.com/q/developer and get
started building right over here. If you
want to see what's new, also check out
there's updates coming through, so be
sure to check that out. And if you have
any questions, let us know in the
comments. And as always, happy building.